Percy proceeding with the count Yoko for
launch
strap back t-minus ten nine eight seven
hang on
each person you speak to has had a day
some of the days have been good some bad
what is it to be human
what is it to be alive tell me why it's
so important for it to say hello
no one said the Java supposed to be easy
no one said it will be there hard
neither we'll figure it out oh you're
some horse that's not how the force
works I blew myself up because I'm
stupid that's not stupidity that's fraud
tell me the difference between stupid
and illegal and I'll have my wife's
brother arrested hey be careful with
that huh no it's okay it's not one
[Music]
what if we had to change to find out how
big a human being I got something to say
that's the best you can do
what a lovely day
drag your seatbelt on who you asking me
that now
sorry about that needed to let off a
little steam
they're all looking at you believe me
they're all looking at you
you're the only one who sees the world
same way I do no one sees the world the
same way you do
[Music]
you just got your staring back at you
that your toughest opponent I believe
that in boxing and I do believe that in
life
I can do this I could do this
you're gonna love it what the world
you